♪ [music] ♪
So let's continue to build on that
proposition of growth coming
from fundamentals by looking at
Tata Motors first and then looking
at Disney, and talking about what to do
when those fundamentals don't hold.
So let's move to Tata Motors.
Just like Deutsche, I'm going
to estimate how much of the net income
Tata Motors puts back into the business,
and how well it reinvests.
But rather than distrusting the
retention ratio, here's what I'm going to
do instead. I'm going to look at how much
of the net income Tata Motors actually
puts into projects, net CapEx and change
in working capital, allowing for the fact
that some of that reinvestment might be
covered by debt. And over the
5 years prior leading into 2013,
Tata Motors' equity reinvestment rate,
the percentage of the net income that they
reinvested back was about 87.7%.
During those five years,
the return on equity the company made
on average again was about 43%.
Notice that the 2013 numbers,
the most recent years' numbers are not
as good, Tata Motors reinvested less in
2013, and had a lower return on equity
in 2013 than over the previous 5 years.
If you ask me what the expected growth
for Tata Motors is going to be,
I can use one of two estimates.
I can assume that the 2013 numbers
are now indicative of the future,
and the product of those two numbers,
the reinvestment rate of 80.5% and the
return on equity of close to 30%
gives me a growth rate of about 24%.
That's using 2013 numbers. If like
Deutsche, I fall back and normalized our
average numbers, I actually get a higher
growth rate because I have a higher equity
reinvestment rate, close to 88%,
and a return on equity of 43%.
The product of those two numbers gives me
a growth rate of 38%. If you're saying,
"Which one is the right one?"
Remember this is valuation,
we don't know what the right number is,
all you can do is make your best judgment.
Now if you look at the process by which
we estimated growth in equity earnings,
the driver for that growth and the value
of that growth is the return on equity.
Just as a tangent, I want to talk a little
bit about how a company can end up with a
higher return on equity.
One is to take really great projects,
you could end up with a higher return
on equity as a consequence.
But here's the other way you could
push up your return on equity.
You could take average projects and
end up with a higher return on equity
by using debt. You're saying,
"How does debt help me?"
When you borrow money, you have
a cost of debt, right? In fact,
you have an after tax cost of debt.
If you're after tax cost of debt is 4%,
and you take projects that are in 10%,
12%, or 15%, equity investors, in a sense,
keep the difference. As you [inaudible],
you can actually decompose the
return on equity for a company into two
components. The first is the return
on capital, think of that as what your
return on equity would have been if you'd
use no debt. Add to that,
the effect of debt. And the effect of debt
is a function of how much debt you use,
which I measure with your debt
to equity ratio, and how much that debt
helps you as an equity investor,
and that's captured by the difference
between the return on capital and your
after tax cost of debt. Put differently,
you can end up with a higher return
on equity because you use a lot of debt,
and that higher return on equity will have
a lower value than a higher return on
equity coming from great projects.
To illustrate that process, let me give
you an example. Let's assume you have a
company with a 15% return on capital,
and after tax cost of debt of 5%,
and a debt to equity ratio of 100%.
Here again, I'm going to use book values
because a return on equity is a book value
concept. This company's return on equity
will be 25%, and here is why.
Fifteen percent is my return on capital,
but because I'm borrowing a dollar of debt
for every dollar of equity and earning a
10% spread, my overall return on equity
is going to be 25%. Notice though,
that that 25% return on equity comes with
a cost, the cost is that you borrowed
more money. And remember,
that when you value equity, you're going
to use a cost of equity that reflects the
beta of your company. And if you remember,
betas are a function of how much you
borrow. So if you have two companies
with a 25% return on equity,
one of which got there with no debt and
one with a lot of debt like this one,
the company that got to the 25% return
on equity without using debt will be worth
more than the company that uses 100% debt
to equity ratio. So it is true,
you can pump up the growth in equity
earnings by using more debt,
but it's not true that that's always going
to lead to a higher value for your equity.
Now, let's get back to measuring
reinvestment rates and growth rates,
and use Disney. But remember,
with Disney, I'm valuing the entire
company, not just the equity
in the company. So here,
I'm going to focus not on the equity
reinvestment rate and return on equity,
but the overall reinvestment rate and the
return on capital. If you remember,
for the most recent year for Disney,
when we looked at the cash flows, we
estimated the reinvestment rate that year
to be about 54%, that's a net CapEx
plus change in working capital,
divided by the after tax operating income.
In that year, Disney's return on capital
was 12.61%. If you take the product of
those two numbers, the reinvestment rate
times return on capital,
the growth rate I get for Disney is 6.8%.
So this approach to estimating growth
based on fundamentals works if you have a
stable return on equity and a stable
return on capital, a predictable value.
But what if you have a company whose
operating margins are changing,
and because they're changing,
you're return equity on equity and your
return on capital are also changing?
You cannot use the equation that I use
for Tata Motors and Disney to come up
with a growth rate for the company.
Here's what you have to do.
You have to start with your top line,
which is revenues, and focus those out
first. Then you've got to project out the
expected operating margins overtime,
and that might reflect either increasing
margins or decreasing margins
depending on what you think will happen
to your company. And then you have to
estimate how much you would reinvest based
on your revenues, not your operating
income. And I use a ratio called the sales
to capital ratio to estimate that
reinvestment. What that allows me to do is
look at the change in revenues and tell
you how much you need to reinvest to get
that change. To illustrate this,
let me use Baidu. For Baidu, here's what
I'm going to project.
I'm going to project pretty high
revenue growth, revenue growth of about
25% a year for the next 5 years,
scaling down over time to a growth rate of
3.5%. Remember, I'm doing everything
in Chinese [inaudible]. So that gives me
projected revenues. For the operating
margin, which is 49% now, I'm going to
assume that overtime competition is
going to push that margin down to 35%,
self-changing margins. Using those
changing margins, I get an operating
income. Using that operating income, I get
after tax operating income.
So far so good, right?
To get my reinvestment, I'll start with a
change in revenue. The change in revenue
comes my growth in revenues.
But to get to my reinvestment, I use the
sales to capital ratio.
The sales to capital ratio for Baidu that
I estimate is 2.64. You're saying,
"What does that tell me?"
Based on that number, here's what I
assume will happen, for every dollar
Baidu invests, I'm expecting it to
create $2.64 in additional revenues.
So to get the $7.169 billion in additional
revenue in year 1, I will need to reinvest
about $2.7 billion in year 1,
that's a 7,169 million divided
by the 2.64, and I do that for each year.
That reinvestment is a composite number,
it includes net CapEx and change in
working capital. And that reinvestment is
what I'm going to subtract out from after
tax operating income to get to free cash
flow to the firm. So let's review,
if you have a company with stable returns
on capital, you can estimate the growth
rate by using the fundamental growth
rate equation. If you have a company with
unstable margins, either increasing or
decreasing margins, you've got to go the
long way, estimate revenues and work done
to cash flows. The endgame in either
case is a free cash flow to the firm.
So let's now talk about estimating growth
for your company. Assuming your last
year's free cash flow as a firm,
start with the fundamentals.
What was your investment rate?
What was your return on capital?
You'll be doing a firm valuation.
What was your equity investment rate?
What was the return on equity if
you're doing an equity valuation?
Estimate a fundamental growth rate.
But before you use it,
stop and ask yourself a question,
"Is my company in steady state?
Are its margin stable?"
If the answer is no,
you might have to shift to the revenue
base model where you start with revenues
and estimate free cash flows to
the firm from those revenues.
♪ [music] ♪